foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
objection
thank you
[Music]
yep
Melvin
you ready for this
do this
spots
[Music]
turn it up
welcome to the Stream
[Music]
Last Resort
the camera got my good side
[Music]
[Applause]
this feels awesome you should try it
[Music]
be careful
you're going down
this is for my fellow Hunters
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
you're hearing this
it means the mission of my people still
has hopeless exists
home for gold will not be Reliant
time
what are you even after
you just love killing dinosaurs lights
your fire does it
or are you in it for the more dangerous
prey your fellow man
Aruba also wants to take Leviathan out
of the picture so she wanted us to get
to that control platform she was trying
to give us something science knew all
about leviathan's malfunctions I I know
what Durbin's going to do
he's going to stab signs in the back
chill
this more game ends
when I'm decided
they are making my world again
right
I tried to stop their world to be but my
uncle became your curse
stop the cycle destroy all the pie guy
[Music]
please
hi everyone I'm takaro hiroka the
director of EXO primal first
I'd like to thank everyone who
participated in the second open beta
test we held in June
once again EXO fighters from all over
the world joined the war games and gave
us some excellent feedback
your comments help us make EXO Primal
the best game it can be thank you all so
much
now then I have some updates to share
since launch is just around the corner
let me Begin by briefly explaining what
players can expect from Exo primal
exoprimal is an online team-based action
game that pits Humanity's Cutting Edge
exosuit technology against history's
most ferocious beasts Dinosaurs the main
game mode Dino survival sees two teams
of five players strive to be the first
to complete all objectives
generally this means fighting dinosaurs
but there are also times where EXO
Fighters battle Head to Head
not to mention some situations where
everyone's on a 10 player team
playing Dino survival rewards players
with story progress experience points
and in-game currency
also players can customize EXO suits
appearance and even upgrade their
performance
of course upgraded exosuits will make
Dino survival that much more fun but
powered up EXO suits also allow players
to tackle the high difficulty missions
in Savage Gauntlet mode
next I'd like to introduce a feature
that is a direct result of your feedback
on release day we'll be implementing a
final mission selection feature let me
explain how it works
after reaching a certain amount of
progress by playing Dino survival you
will be able to select one of three
final mission types when matchmaking PVP
e and random
there are a few exceptions but selecting
PVE generally means that final missions
will not involve PVP combat instead
whichever team completes all missions
fastest will be victorious
of course players who select PVP can
expect the same Mission variety that was
available in the beta tests although
your final mission selection preference
won't impact story progress
selecting the random option will provide
an experience Point bonus
and don't worry you can change your
selection preference at any time
PVE PVP or random choose whatever mode
suits your mood
now I'd like to talk about exoprimals
roadmap for release day and Beyond
EXO Primal will feature in-game Seasons
that are three months long
season will come with a title update
that adds new game content
survival pass will be overhauled with
new rewards each season
one will kick off on launch Day July
14th we'll be introducing the new Savage
Gauntlet mode just two weeks later on
July 28th
you'll want to upgrade and better
understand your exosuits before
attempting Savage Gauntlet we also have
a new video for you to enjoy
two Lorenzo's inspecting the new
equipment
Jedi Alpha eliminates enemies with two
different attacks
[Music]
pepper Alpha can strike distant enemies
thanks to the dragon chakra
[Music]
barrage Alpha's rocket launcher can blow
your enemies to the Beats five
[Music]
Vigilant Alpha semi-automatic rifle
meets the need for accurate suppressive
fire
roadblock Alpha's Deployable Shield
frees you up to defend and fight
for Max stuffing power trying Krieger
Alpha's chargeable shotgun
[Music]
murasame Alpha's ice cold counters
locked down enemies so allies can break
the pain
which Dr Alpha's Duality heals allies
and harms enemies
need to stop them in their tracks rain
down lightning with Sky wave out
Nimbus Alpha shotgun is ranked number
one in close combat
thank you
[Music]
exoprimal's First Title Update will go
live on August 16th
and get this we're adding 10 Alpha
variant exosuits all at once
Alpha variance existence feature
completely different weapons and play
styles from their default counterparts
put Alpha suits to good use in Dino
survival and Savage gauntlet
season two will begin in mid-october of
course Title Update 2 will drop at the
same time
date will feature the street fighter 6
collaboration content we recently
announced
we'll also be adding new Rigs and
modules a new map a new final mission
and more
season three is scheduled to start in
January 2024. the beta variant suits
will be added along with the
terrifyingly powerful Neo Triceratops
we also plan on conducting our second
Capcom collaboration during season three
with the monster hunter series keep an
eye out for more info on that down the
road the EXO Primal team has a ton of
great stuff in the works but I can't say
much more at the moment
so that'll be all for now we sure
covered a lot of ground today remember
exoprimal Launches on July 14th not only
will you enjoy pulse pounding action as
dinosaurs and exosuits Collide you'll
also see the story of the hammerheads
through to the thrilling conclusion
as I mentioned earlier we plan on
supporting exoprimal with new content
even after the game's release
we'll have more information on future
content updates at a later date
until then we hope to see you in the war
games it'll be massively fun
[Music]
thank you
foreign